ils sont des milliers en cette fin de
semaine à défiler dans les rues de
rangoon trois doigts levés vers le ciel
le signe de ralliement des manifestants
ce qu'ils dénoncent le coup d'état
militaire du 1er février intervenus près
de trois mois après le raz-de-marée
électoral du parti de la démocrate omson
succi les protestataires exigent la
libération de cette dernière est celle
des autres dirigeants arrêtés lors de la
prise de pouvoir par la tâte matao le
nom de l'armée birmane
je me joins à cette marche parce que
notre gouvernement élu et est menacé par
les militaires la dictature militaire
n'est conforme à aucune loi le pouvoir
de l'état a été injustement confisqué
par les militaires il ne respecte pas la
volonté du peuple et je pense qu'ils
trahissent le pays
nous allons nous battre jusqu'au bout et
aujourd'hui notre révolution a démarré
nous manifesterons jusqu'à ce qu'ils
libèrent nos dirigeants nous exigeons la
libération de notre présidente
et nous voulons une véritable démocratie
nous nous battrons jusqu'au bout
les événements que se sont empressés de
dénoncer de nombreux acteurs de la
communauté internationale l'union
européenne condamne avec la plus grande
fermeté le coup d'état militaire
perpétré en birmanie il s'agit d'une
tentative inacceptable de renverser par
la force la volonté du peuple birman
mieux examinera toutes les options à sa
disposition pour faire en sorte que la
démocratie l'emportent elles la
communauté internationale doit parler
d'une seule voix pour exiger de l'armée
birmane qu'elle rende immédiatement le
pouvoir
les états unis défendront la démocratie
partout où elle est attaquée ces
développements porte un coup dur aux
réformes démocratiques en birmanie
tous les dirigeants doivent agir dans le
plus grand intérêt de la réforme
démocratique en birmanie s'engager dans
un dialogue constructif s'abstenir de
toute violence et respecter pleinement
les droits de l'homme et les libertés
fondamentales
les forces armées bien man ont désormais
un objectif freiner la contestation
outre la mise en place d'importants
dispositifs de maintien de l'ordre
plusieurs coupures d'internet ont été
constatés depuis lundi restreignant
notamment l'accès aux réseaux sociaux
je